Alrighty then, it is time for Drew's News,
your daily grating of the fresh news Parmigiano.
And with me at the desk is my best co-pilot ever,
Ross Mathews!
Yeah. Hi.
(audience applauds and cheers)
Parmigiano.
Parmigiano!
All right.
First up in the news,
we're all guilty of a little impulse purchase now and then,
and The Cut reports that Nicolas Cage
just revealed one of his.
It's a two-headed snake,
and he bought it for $80,000.
What?
He said he had a dream about a two-headed eagle,
and then, the next day,
he heard that the two-headed snake was for sale
and he was like, "Pfhht, obviously".
So unfortunately, it turns out
the two heads did not get along.
He tried putting a spatula in between them at feedings
but he said it just got too freaky.
And if it's too freaky for Nicolas Cage,
it's gotta be freaky.
Yeah.
(audience laughs)
But he safely returned them to a zoo.
You know, when we tell kids,
they went to that "farm".
Yeah, yeah.
Living in a, yeah.
Yeah, well,
that's where these snakes went.
Ross, thought.
I mean, this is something that only Nicolas Cage would do.
Right? A two-headed snake.
But the freakiest part of the story
is that the heads didn't get along.
I know.
Right?
Can you imagine, you're a two-headed snake?
For starters, you're like, "Man!"
And then the worst part is like, you don't like each other.
What?
Are you coming over here to be my...?
(Drew laughs)
Come here, you got...
Where are you coming?
I'm gonna be a two headed snake with you.
Watch.
(audience hoots and applauds)
You would not need any spatula between us.
Maybe we are a two headed snake, Rossy.
Can you imagine if you didn't like your other head,
and it was just some jerk snake,
who ate tuna salad and it's breath always smelled,
right next to your face.
(Drew laughs)
Um, wow.
Have you ever done something like that?
Like bought something impulsively and regretted it?
Oh my God.
Haven't we all?
Yeah, it may not have been a two-headed snake.
It was not a two-headed snake.
I'll buy an old flea market Scandinavian table
because it folds up into a console this big,
but then it expands out to a
amazing 12 person dinner table.
And I'm like "One day I'm gonna make this table."
Yeah.
Those are my impulse purchases.
You're gonna make it.
My impulse purchase is a sweater with horizontal stripes.
I always think, "Oh, I can pull that off."
And then I get it home,
and I'm like, "I can't pull that off, I can't.
You feel like the Hamburglar?
Total Hamburglar.
(Drew laughs)
That's what I look like in horizontal stripes.
You'll never see it.
No, you look good.
All right, well next, we've got a new trend in makeup.
And Drew, I want your take on this.
For a while, you know, it's been all about
keeping it minimal,
with a very no makeup kind of look.
But now NYLON reports it's all about party girl aesthetic,
and it's happening in beauty and in fashion.
And it's described as a look that's sort of
messy at times, but real,
which also describes this show, (chuckles) okay.
Oh my God, it really does.
Right?
We are messy, but real.
We keep it real, but it gets a little messy around here.
But in this trend they're talking about
popping some sparkly eye makeup,
but also pairing it with a messy bun or a ponytail.
Are you into this look?
I love it.
You do?
I do.
I knew you would.
I do, because I started this company, FLOWER Beauty,
10 years ago, and we,
it was the birth of Instagram,
and then it was the heavy contour,
kind of all the tips and tricks we could teach each other
over social media.
It became a lot about artistry, really.
And I think, you know, "Drag Race" had a lot to do
with stuff like that.
Aww, yeah.
We got into the theatrics,
and then, all of a sudden,
for the last few years, it's super fresh face, pandemic.
We, you know, everything comes full circle.
And now this sort of sexy, smoky, leftover,
party girl thing, Euphoria inspired, something youthful.
It's a little, I just am into it.
Well, I think that all sort of,
it's because of what we've been through
for the past couple of years.
We've all been at home in our elastic clothing, right?
Watching makeup tutorials with our hair in a bun.
And now they open the doors out and we're like,
"Well, this is the new look.
(audience laughs)
This is,
this is now fashion and get into it."
That's exactly right.
It's a little bit of a hybrid.
It's a little nineties, I'm into it.
(bright theme music)